today i'm going to give you the number
one best tip
for intermittent fasting weight loss
results now i am going to give you more
tips than just one but i want to give
you
the most important tip but starting with
some other tips that might not be as
important now a lot of people are doing
intermittent fasting with either minimum
or moderate results
they're not achieving what they could
achieve
if they knew what i'm about to tell you
so if you're going to do fasting might
as well do it correctly and get as much
results as you can and of course in this
video we're focused on weight loss but
there's so many other benefits uh
building a new immune system
growing new brain tissue
improving your mood
improving your cognitive function focus
memory
concentration
and dropping your inflammation whether
you have an autoimmune problem or you
have
allergies or you have irritable bowel
syndrome or arthritis
intermittent fasting is so beneficial
for those things but most people do it
for weight loss
all right let's start with number six
first and number six is really
understanding what's happening in your
body when you're doing fasting
um you're not starving your body you're
actually mimicking something that our
bodies were designed
to
operate with which is
not eating so frequently so what's
happening is you're activating certain
genes
that increase survival and i'm not
talking about just barely surviving i'm
talking about thriving i'm also talking
about turning off genes
that are disease genes turning off
cancer genes basically you just turn off
the bad stuff and you turn on the good
stuff you're actually targeting
improving
insulin sensitivity
you're making insulin
way more sensitive so it can work again
because insulin resistance is at the
heart of the very reason why you are
overweight in the first place and have a
difficult time losing weight and have a
certain set point that you can't seem to
get below it's the insulin if you have
too much insulin because you have
insulin resistance
it's going to be very difficult to lose
weight so fasting is the most important
thing
to fix that problem in fact fasting is
the most important health creating thing
you can do in your life so many diseases
and chronic health problems are
connected to high insulin and so you're
fixing years of bad eating and eating
way too many carbs when you do fasting
all right so that understanding is very
very important going into this because
it's not just a little thing you're
doing something very very important
all right number five adding
hit or high intensity interval training
now what is
high intensity interval training well
that is short periods of high intense
exercise with a good amount of rest so
you're doing this full body exercise
but not very long just short intervals
that way you can spike growth hormone by
700 percent you can produce way better
results in doing the treadmill thing for
45 minutes at a moderate pace so high
intensity interval training will greatly
help you
if you don't do it too frequently you
want to do it
once or twice a week with a lot of rest
in between because if you do it like
some people i know every day
the results just go way down why because
you don't have a chance to recover and
all of your results occur in the
recovery so we want to create this
stimulus and then let the body recover
and do its magic and so if we combine
this type of exercise with fasting we're
going to see better results all right
number four there are certain herbal
teas
that
specifically target those insulin
receptors and make insulin more
sensitive remember i mentioned this
weight loss is all about correcting this
insulin problem so anything you can do
to fix insulin sensitivity is going to
help you lose weight so it's not about
taking supplements or teas that
stimulate your metabolism it's about
drinking teas or even supplements that
help this insulin sensitivity and
there's two t's that i'm going to
recommend one is berberine which is
probably just as effective as a
medication called metformin which they
use for diabetes metformin
helps you improve insulin sensitivity
and so does berberine so berberine would
be a great tea to start drinking through
the day the other tea that's really good
is green tea so both of those teas are
what i'm going to recommend and there's
something else that's not a tea but it
can help you apple cider vinegar so
you can do a teaspoon or a tablespoon
and a glass of water okay because you're
diluting it you're not taking it
directly
it's not going to bother your teeth too
much but you could
drink it through a straw if you're
concerned i like to add a little lemon
with that or even blend an entire lemon
with the apple cider vinegar
and then drink it down with a straw
because now we have the lemon which is
an acid but those things can actually
help you as well all right number three
being consistent now if you weigh
yourself
every single day
you're not going to see much and it's
going to be discouraging if you look at
yourself in the mirror from one day to
the next you're not going to see any
difference because it's going to be so
gradual and the chances of you dropping
off go up if you're discouraged and you
don't see results
so the best thing to do
is take a picture of yourself don't show
anyone
and
do another picture of yourself maybe in
two weeks or even this is better yeah a
month so you can really see some changes
that are occurring you have to really
acknowledge that this problem has been
going on for a very very long time and
it's going to take some time to undo
and in the process of
doing this it can be discouraging if
you're not seeing results but just
realize it is working
and one of the best indicators to know
it's working is that your appetite and
cravings will go away that's what i want
you to focus on as well as maybe your
clothes fitting looser maybe your energy
improving your mood improving but not
the weight loss it's get healthy first
then lose weight
not the other way around your body
considers this extra fat as a survival
mechanism and it doesn't like to get rid
of survival so what you have to do is
focus on
really getting your body healthy and a
big part of that is fixing insulin and
it takes some consistency if you're
doing it sort of
or
let's say you're doing the ketogenic
diet like not quite consistent
your results are not going to be there
and so you're going to have to really
bite the bullet and do it for real just
a tiny bit of carbs
whether that's a half a glass of wine
every other day
or maybe a little snack of some
carbohydrate like a piece of bread can
severely block your progress for up to
48 hours
so
if you're doing something that's not on
the program every other day
and you're not seeing results realize
that
you just knocked yourself out of ketosis
and you never give your body a chance to
be in ketosis long enough to really see
the results it's the little things that
you need to avoid that will make a huge
difference number two doing the healthy
version of the ketogenic diet with
intermittent fasting they both
complement each other
what are we trying to do we're trying to
fix insulin resistance how do you do
that well you lower your carbs and you
don't eat so frequently and this is why
intermittent fasting with lowering your
carbs is going to be essential if you're
doing intermittent fasting and you're
eating a lot of carbs
don't expect a lot of great results
unless your metabolism is already really
good and you haven't created insulin
resistance which is rare
most people have insulin resistance they
just never were tested by it because
their doctor never did a test called
homa ir
and never evaluated the fasting insulin
levels okay they looked at the blood
sugar levels but not the fasting insulin
levels if you want more information
about that
i put a link down below now with number
two recommendation healthy ketogenic
diet
i want to emphasize nutrient dense foods
on this program so i highly recommend
you don't make a habit of eating out
much why because the food at restaurants
unfortunately has too many
bad things and they don't focus on
nutrient-dense foods and there's a lot
of like omega-6 corn oils and soy oils
in the food and you really don't know
what you're getting so it's better if
you control your own food and focus on
things like eggs salmon grass-fed
hamburger big salads
the more
nutrient empty your foods are the more
of that food you have to eat
to get healthy
so why not focus on nutrient-dense foods
unfortunately farmers are paid on weight
and yields not the nutrition in those
fields so
i've done a lot of videos on this and i
will put some links down below but doing
the healthy version of keto with
intermittent fasting
is number two in importance all right
let's do number one
are you sitting down for this okay
transition from your two meals a day to
one meal a day that's called omad now
why is this so important
well
you get 23 hours of fasting
and that's when the magic happens
when you transition from this
18 hours of fasting or 16 hours of
fasting or 20 hours of fasting to 23
hours of fasting it's huge your liver
has a chance to really regenerate your
entire digestive system has a chance to
reset the insulin receptors that have
been so downgraded start becoming
extremely sensitive your ketones start
increasing by three times
and your body is finally becoming fat
adapted to the point where if you did go
off the program your body can bounce
back fairly easily in other words if you
do omad your body becomes a fat burning
machine
so my most important tip for immune
fasting is to do a lot of it okay
especially if you have a slow metabolism
especially if you're not seeing results
with weight loss now that you have some
really important
information underneath your belt um you
need the details
of how to do intermittent fasting and i
put that video up right here check it
out
you